dodgers going for the sweep today behind
clayton kershaw winning game one one
nothing winning last night 9-5
no for kershaw six runs on ten hits in
his season opener opening day in
colorado but he followed that up with a
much different outing monday in oakland
one run over seven innings
bouncing ball to seeger is short robles
out number one
as the sixth highest percentage in his
big league career
and he threw that slider trey turner
swings at the first one that he sees and
knocks a base hit into center that's
first fastball
opening day of colorado gets the first
base hit of the day there is an achilles
heel to clayton's arsenal it is the
first pitch bottom of the first inning
36 year old reinhander max scherzer
taking the hill for the nationals
gavin lux leading off backs into the
wine the first pitch fastball is sky to
the air to shallow left and this is
trouble turner going out in comes the
left fielder and a collision between
turner and yadiel hernandez
who went down and then turner flipped
over him a little bit a glancing blow
but awkwardly as he made the catch and
then was knocked off his feet
hernandez got him in the lower leg area
and turner was on his feet now down to a
knee
and that was kind of the into the
bermuda triangle no man's land and again
second straight start the opponent has
swung at scherzer's first pitch of the
game
so max 175 the win total one fewer than
kershaw making his 370th start seeger in
the series one for eight with a walk
got up and in on him short right field
jordy mercier
he's got a shortstop's arm no problem
for him two down the 1-0
swing in a long drive to left field but
playable for hernandez moving toward the
line makes the catch for the out there
retires the side that one
maybe a lot down towards the end of the
bat didn't quite have the distance and
it's a one two three inning for max
scherzer making his 370th career start
379th game are you going to compare he
and kershaw in terms of wins career wins
they're one apart kershaw's 176 and 77
99 games above 500.
muncie yanks the mission down the line
to right soda was positioned over there
he's already there and will hold muncie
to his single max muncie
continues to find ways to get on base
for muncie above 550 now
second in the national league behind new
york's brandon nemo
leadoff man on first base runner of the
game for the dodgers and here's taylor
here's his 2-2
taylor sends one the other way back goes
soto shout out the track to put it away
two out for mckinstry muncie off first
he had a leadoff single another 3-2
pitch mckenstry waits on it sends it to
near the left center roble is in it
first now out to the track and he lost
it in the sun
the dodgers and the los angeles
a bad break the left fielder hernandez
coming over but it looked like he
thought robles was going to make the
play
a bad break for max scherzer two
celebrations and one from the rookie two
balls two strikes
[Applause]
looked like a strike for a while didn't
it then it was too late
three consecutive swinging strikeouts
cutter under the hands perfectly placed
90 miles an hour watch
looks like a fastball go to swing it
just slides underneath your bat and your
hands two down home third one nothing
los angeles here's the one two
swinging a hard line drive out in the
shift and the outfield mercer has it on
one bounce he pirouettes and fires to
zimmerman and that is out number three
seeger hit it hard but the side retired
one two three go the dodgers one nothing
los angeles after three
[Applause]
fernando's family getting us started
here on fernando valenzuela day at
dodger stadium what a special weekend
this has been i've got to imagine this
is a particularly special day for you
fernando our good friend joins us in the
booth but
40 years
really
what
that's crazy isn't it
it is it is here's chris taylor
3-2 coming to taylor swing and a miss on
a change-up he struck him out so max
fans two and a one two three inning he
has five strikeouts on the board we go
to the fifth
need to gap one or get one down a line
somewhere let some people run beyond
first base
bounced along third they'll have to pray
that this thing rolls foul out he might
get a double out of it
there it goes oh my goodness
fair ball infield single trey turner you
couldn't have walked out there and set
it on the line any more direct swinging
and it is a perfect bunt justin turner
you see him [ __ ] his head towards first
like i can't let him round first and go
to second scots have had their chances
today first one has been able to slam
the bill each time
can he do it again in the sixth the
payoff pitch
a slider from kershaw his sixth
strikeout of the game
no runs one hit one left max has only
had three ground ball outs in the game
majority of his outs in the air are on
strikes he is not running the pitch
swinging a line drive caught by zimmet
first he'll step on the bag for the
double play
how do you like that that's a huge break
with zim holding the runner he catches
the line drive and steps on first
in front of beatty
for the big double play
fancy footwork
seeger off second
the 1-0 to turner swinging a tapper
towards short softly hit trey turner has
it for the second straight time he
throws out justin turner and scherzer
survives a lead-off walk and a double in
the inning shot scherzer has been as
advertised and it looks like max day may
be finished getting the handshakes high
fives
through six innings at 90 pitches
for our first two gone here's mckenstry
who's driven in the game's only run
swings away this time walks it to right
center field back towards the rolling
gun
zach mckinstry a tow run home run
he's driven in all three
dodgers and mckinstry three
the nationals nothing well this guy's a
baseball player when you're a baseball
player you do anything you can to help
the team win so now here's soto
[Applause]
and soto will pop it up to center for
taylor got a slider
blake tried in two huge pitches
frustrated juan soto got a hanging
slider at that desoto couldn't get the
good wood to it you see the reaction
from the young lefty zim is over three
eight for 20 for the year right now he's
bounced to short struck out bounced to
short all against the starter kershaw
softly hit treynan's there throws to
first
in time and the inning is over
[Applause]
[Applause]
good to see you
three nothing the final score they sweep
the nationals and start the season 8-2
[Applause]